your cause owns a power that has not
been seen in this world since the days
of old valyria
dragons we have Cyrax caraxes and mes B
has moonan Damon none of our dragons
have been to war there are also
unclaimed dragons sea smoke still
resides on drift Mar veror and silver
wind dwell on the Dragon Mountain Still
ridless then there are the three wild
dragons all of whom Nest here and who is
to ride them Dragon Stone has 13 to
their
[Applause]
fall there has never lived a stark who
forgot an oath and with how Stark the
north will
follow we have no friends among the
lanister The House of the Dragon does
not seem to know who rules it
for free you can now listen to the
entire Audi book Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire targaryan history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using our Link in the
description